petite séance d'échauffement pour les
étoiles du jour marie-france charlène
josette manuela gérald et les autres des
ailes du sport des femmes de toutes
obédiences politiques sportives
culturelles bien présente à cette
cinquième édition un moment de chaleur
de fraternité ces dames ont su se faire
mieux reconnaître qu on connaître balle
au pied que ce soit dans le monde
économique dans le monde associatif dans
le monde politique la femme droit
s'impliquer et c'est ce que nous voyons
aujourd'hui il ya tout un panel de
femmes des politiques les journalistes
les anciennes gloires de football donc
tout le monde est là et ça se passe très
bien c'est surtout aussi un moment de
partager un moment aussi on dit que on
demande que la femme sait dépasser
certaines limites
on n'est pas toujours aujourd'hui dans
des tentes dans des sentiers battus
qu'on nous a forcément un imposé devant
un public de connaisseurs les deux
équipes ont démontré leur potentialité
amont du sport et du ballon des femmes
diop qui n'ont eu aucune honte à taper
dans le ballon
un moment convivial pour les néophytes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'important pour nous c'est aujourd'hui
c'est de nous rencontrer de jouer
ensemble de passer un bon moment et
c'est pas vraiment le résultat c'est
c'est vraiment voilà c'est l'occasion de
tout ceux rencontrés là vraiment prouver
qu'il n'ya pas d'étiquette unamic les
étiquettes qu'elles soient politiques ou
médiatiques de côté pour vraiment se
retrouver unis dans une seule et même
équipe
ce qu'on apprécie dans cette forme de
rencontre c'est qu'on ne parle pas du
travail on n'échange pas sur les
différents dossiers je parle notamment
des politiques
là il n'est pas question de ça on
s'appelle par nos prénoms et ça se passe
dans une très bonne omnium futsal
spécial femmes que l'eau soit un député
journaliste animatrice et autres un tout
qui donne une force supplémentaire à
celle qui par le passé ont fait vibrer
le coeur des martiniquais sur les
terrains de foot
c'est un moment convivial en dehors du
résultat il est important qu'on se
retrouve pour effectivement voir la
femme d'une manière générale sur tous
ces personnalités sous d'autres formes
l'unique occasion quand même deux
réunions sportives animateurs et
journalistes et élus politiques et vous
montrer par les édiles politiques ne
sont pas inaccessibles
score final 7 à 6 pour les gloires le
plus important reste et demeure cette
fraternité tisser entre ces femmes
rendez-vous en 2020